bonjour à tous bienvenue sur l'antenne
de lcp public sénat on va refaire l'actu
politique et parlementaire de la semaine
c'est l'heure de parlement hebdo avec
michael annett bonjour katia bonjour
michael cette semaine a été marquée par
le départ de christiane taubira du
gouvernement celle qui sera resté près
de quatre ans garde des sceaux a quitté
le gouvernement en raison d'un désaccord
politique majeure at-elle dit jean
jacques urvoas la remplace même jour de
ce départ manuel valls étaient devant la
commission des lois pour présenter la
nouvelle formule retenue sur la
déchéance de nationalité
la référence aux binationaux a disparu
du texte mais la polémique elle continue
et puis remarquer cette semaine de
dialogue de sourds dans l'hémicycle sur
le projet notre dame des landes cécile
duflot a interpellé le gouvernement sur
ce dossier sensible
réponse cinglante du premier ministre on
verra tout à l'heure et pour commenter
toute cette actualité christophe
caresche et notre invité bonjour bonjour
vous êtes député du parti socialiste
député de paris vous faites partie de
ceux que l'on appelle le pôle des
réformateurs les réformateurs
ce sont ceux qui sont sur la ligne de
manuel valls on est bien d'accord avec
cela oui vous allez l'autre la mort vous
avez consulté et vous expliquer dans un
instant va commencer que c'est par la
suite de nos sujets
soixante et une proposition lundi pour
rappeler les principes fondamentaux du
code du travail c'est le rapport pain
d'inter l'ancien garde des sceaux de
françois mitterrand a remis son travail
à manuel valls le rapport servira de
base au projet de loi présenté par
myriam el khomri stéphanie des pierres
c'est l'acteur de la réforme du code du
travail
robert badinter a remis son rapport à
manuel valls rédigé par un comité de
neuf juriste le texte réaffirme
clairement la place du cdi
pas question non plus de remettre en
cause le smic sur les heures
supplémentaires le rapport badinter ne
prend pas vraiment position mais il
martèle l'idée que tout salarié qui
travaille plus de 35 heures a droit à
une compensation
le premier ministre lui aussi écarte
toute remise en cause des 35 heures il y
a une durée légale normale du temps de
travail
elle est aujourd'hui fixée à 35 heures
de mal peut être modifié enfin c'est pas
le sens de ce que nous préparons le
gouvernement veut simplifier le code du
travail le rendre plus lisible et plus
souple mais pour la droite il faut
accélérer les réformes
je crains que ce ne soit un ebe à une
forme d mobilise ce maquereau a fait des
déclarations
nous attendons aujourd'hui qu'elle se
traduise en actes les 35 heures
aujourd'hui sont une source de blocage
or nageurs il faut lever cette source de
blocage si vous ne touchez pas
réellement dans l'année 2016 au temps de
travail si vous ne touchez pas à ce que
le contrat unique
je vois pas bien en quoi ça peut
permettre la création d'emplois les 61
principes énoncés par le rapport
badinter deviendront le préambule du
nouveau code du travail
ils guideront évidemment le projet de
loi de réforme du code du travail
mais rien belle connerie le présentera
le 9 mars prochain en conseil des
ministres alors ce rapport christophe
caresche ne veut pas toucher ni aux 35
heures n'est au cddp salaire minimum à
quoi va-t-il servir si c'est pour ne
toucher à rien du tout si si d'abord
c'est un projet très important parce que
le chômage continue de progresser dans
notre pays on a fait un certain nombre
de choses mais on voit bien que il faut
aller plus loin et même aujourd'hui
alors qu'on n'est pas très loin de 2017
je pense que le gouvernement a raison de
vouloir continuer à essayer de trouver
des solutions et à réformer
je partage qui est dit c'est à dire il
faut que ces réformes soient
suffisamment significative pour qu'elle
ait des effets et ce morceau
significative je pense que la logique
est proposée notamment par robert
badinter qui est de dire et par le
gouvernement qui est de dire on va
renvoyer toute une série de choses à la
négociation soit dans les branches dans
les entreprises c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important c'est même une
petite révolution dans ce pays parce que
cela signifie que va se négocier au plus
près du besoin des andes et entreprises
toute une série de choses notamment
bon alors également le débat est assez
technique mais notamment la question du
temps de travail on le touchera la toile
des 35 heures ne touche certes pas aux
35 heures mais on va toucher à la
manière dont les discuter les heurts qui
sont travaillés au delà des 35 heures
excuse parce qu'il ya des gens
aujourd'hui il ya des gens aujourd'hui
qu'ils travaillent plus de 35 heures
dans ce pays
est ce que vous auriez souhaité vous
qu'on touche aux 35 heures non je trouve
que c'est un débat très comment
dirais-je symbolique comme on les aime
dans ce pays
c'est un tableau c'est ed oui espèce de
deux tabous c'est d'aimer encore y
croire quand on regarde la réalité ce
débat il n'a pas beaucoup de sens
la suppression des 35 heures ça voudrait
dire roi ça vous dit ça voudrait dire
qu'on allonge de temps de travail sans
payer les
supplémentaires ce que propose certaines
personnalités de la droite dans leur
programme riche et notamment il ya un
rapport au sénat qui le propose
ce n'est pas ni ce que propose
évidemment le premier ministre ni ce que
propose d'ailleurs emmanuel macron il
n'a jamais proposé cela ce que l'on
propose c'est de dire qu'il peut y avoir
une marge de négociation sur la compte
la valorisation du puisque au delà de 35
heures
vous avez un seuil minimum qui est de 25
% ou 10 % d'augmentation du salaire de
leurs supplémentaires ce qu'on propose
c'est que cette question soit soumise à
la négociation il des manuels mais qu'on
n'a pas réussi à passer là si si si vous
aurait négligé ce soir c'est à dire on
s'en va pas être trop technique mais
aurait alors faire et que ce soit en
dessous en bas d'abord moi je considère
que ça se discute ça ça fait partie de
la discussion reste à négocier c'est
négocier ça fera partie de la discussion
au parlement
bon moi ça ne me choque pas qu'on aille
en dessous des 10% qu'est ce que dit
emmanuel macron c'est exactement la même
logique qu'il a eu sur le travail du
dimanche
le travail du dimanche on a dit c'est
aux partenaires sociaux de négocier les
compensations salariales
il y avait un certain nombre de députés
notamment benoît hamon je me souviens
très bien
qui dit faux fixé à 5 minimum monsieur
macron a dit non parce que il faut
d'abord faire confiance aux partenaires
sociaux et deuxièmement en fixant un
seuil minimum vous allez mettre tout le
monde au seuil bon ce qui s'est passé et
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui dans la
négociation c'est qu'on constate que les
syndicats obtiennent énormément
énormément ils obtiennent des avancées
très significatives sur les salaires
donc il faut faire confiance aux
syndicats et moi je considère qu'il n'a
pas nécessité de fixer un seuil on va
voir aussi sur les autres textes que
vous pensez et notamment aussi sur les
manifestations au toujours curieux mardi
une forte mobilisation dans la rue
notamment du secteur des fonctionnaires
mais il ya eu aussi les taxis qui ont
mobilisé toute la semaine
regardez ce reportage d'elsa monde un
gamin qui va vous expliquer un petit peu
tout ce qui s'est passé autour des taxis
et notamment des explications sur cette
loi thévenoud qui va être modifié sans
2014 une proposition de loi était
adoptée elle devait pacifier les
relations entre les taxis et les vtc
oui il ya de la place pour tout le monde
d'un côté modernisation des taxis avec
par exemple terminal de carte bancaires
obligatoires
d'autre part interdiction pour les bd
c'est de circuler sont réservés sur
préalable
mais selon l'auteur de la loi thomas
thévenoud celle ci n'est à ce jour pas
correctement appliqué pour un des
raisons de deux moyens parce que c'est
vrai qu'il faut déployer les forces de
police aujourd'hui la police des taxis
ces 90 bauer on les appelle comme ça
pour 20000 taxi et 7 millions et essayez
donc évidemment ils sont fort peu
nombreux plusieurs incidents se sont
produits donnant lieu à une vingtaine
d'arrestations
le premier ministre a condamné ces
violences manuel valls le ministre de
l'intérieur et celui des transports ont
ensuite reçu à matignon une délégation
de représentants d'organisations
professionnelles de taxi et les réunions
se sont succédé toute la semaine toute
la semaine a été marquée par cette grève
des taxis avec des violences aussi quand
même très voire trop trop vous condamner
tout cela oui je condamne tout cela tu
veux dire une chose très très clair
c'est les taxis sont d'abord victimes
d'un système qui a été encouragée
d'ailleurs accepté en tous les cas par
l'état mais qui a été aussi accepté par
la profession elle-même qui a consisté à
créer à mettre sur le marché des
licences administrative a créé une
véritable bulle autour de ces licences
qui ont été multipliées par quatre
depuis les années 2000
et je comprends que les taxis et
notamment les derniers taxi qui sont
arrivés et qu'ils ont acheté ces
licences se préoccupent de leur avenir
ils ont raison mais la question ce n'est
pas d'empêcher les autres de travailler
c'est pas ça la question
la question c'est de régler ce problème
alors et donc il faut maintenant
affronter ce problème c'est comment on
fait parce qu'évidemment cette bulle
elle va finir un jour ou l'autre par
explose là c'est le cas donc la question
elle est en train effectivement
d'exploser naturellement est bon il ya
des responsabilités
il ya au passage quand même des gens qui
sont venus pas mal dans la dent dans la
poche
enfin parce que ces licences elles ont
été donnés gratuitement elles sont
aujourd'hui à plus de 2
elles étaient 200 ceux qui ont acheté
des licences dans les années 2000 qui
étaient autour de quelques de 40000
euros elle coûtait à l'époque quarante
ou cinquante mille euros
elles ont été jusqu'à 200 milles euros
vous voyez la plus belle une changement
des choses depuis on a l'impression
qu'ils aient que c'est un peu la
cacophonie que ce secteur est un peu
livré à lui-même et ce qu'il faut que
l'état est at il les moyens de reprendre
un peu
moi je je pense que ce c'est qu'il ya ce
problème des taxis ça je pense qu'il
faut que l'état
moi je pense qu emmanuel macron a fait
des propositions intéressantes règle ce
qu'on essaye de trouver une sortie sur
cette question des licences mais là
mentalement c'est ça qui à mon avis
plombe le dossier il ya la situation des
vtc
alors je parle de la situation des vtc
je considère d'aborder avec chauffeur
pour ces cas là je considère d'abord que
il y a un potentiel de croissance dans
ce secteur très important
donc il ya de la place pour tout le
monde pour parler clairement et je crois
que l'état aurait tort de freiner le
développement des vtc et notamment je
demande au gouvernement de prendre
l'arrêté sur les formations des
chauffeurs est toujours pas pris et qui
bloque aujourd'hui la formation de
recoudre record d'agassi rhône et rhône
et accès aux dépens de nantes je pense
que il y a chez certains l'idée est
notamment aussi de l'opérateur qui est
quand même très en position dominante
chez les taxis
il ya une volonté de de faire porter la
rue d'une responsabilité qui est la leur
qui élabore la leur sur les autres ça ce
n'est pas acceptable qu'il faut remettre
de l'ordre dans tout ça est appelé je
sais ce que nous faisons c'est vrai que
la loi thévenoud disons le clairement ça
a été une ligne maginot
bon allez l'image de noël sont
contournées parce qu'elle a passée avait
un grand chose pour vous elle a pas
servi à grand chose si elle a un pommeau
la situation mais sur une plaie il y
avait un certain nombre de dispositions
quitté qui sont pas appliquées parce
qu'elle était inapplicable
j'ai vu arriver les amendements au
dernier moment j'étais dans l'émission
moi j'ai dénoncé ça quand j'ai vu
arriver les amendements où on demandait
aux vtc de retourner à la base etc
c'est des trucs qui sont appliquées il
faut une nouvelle au husa il faut la loi
je moi je suis pas un fanatique de la
législation à tout prix c'est pas dans
la loi qu on règle tous les problèmes
mais il faut retrouver effectivement une
une comment dirais-je un cadre dans le
cas qui permettent à tout le monde de se
développer et il faut régler le problème
des taxis et le problème des taxis c'est
les licences celi s'est dit on va
poursuivre la semaine
une passe d'armes a eu lieu christophe
caresche à l'assemblée sur le projet de
construction de l'aéroport notre dame
des landes vous étiez dans l'hémicycle
cécile duflot s'est fait répondre
sèchement par manuel valls écouter le
président de la république françois
hollande a déclaré en direct à la radio
le 5 janvier 2015
tant que les recours ne sont pas
épuisées le projet ne peut pas être
lancé à ce jour plus de dix sept recours
sont toujours en cours y compris au
niveau européen
il porte notamment sur la loi sur l'eau
et la biodiversité ma question est
simple
pouvez vous nous confirmer ici monsieur
le premier ministre que vous ne trahirai
pas la parole du président de la
république je le rappelle ce projet est
en effet soutenu par l'ensemble des
collectivités locales il s'agit de qui
madame duflot du président du conseil
départemental du président du conseil
régional qui est chez la même position
que de son prédécesseur de la maire de
nantes de plusieurs parlementaires de
l'ancien premier ministre jean-marc
ayrault nous vous étiez vous-même
membres du gouvernement ont-ils tort
madame duflot koné style moins bien que
vous la réalité du terrain
on a l'impression que cécile duflot
manuel valls sont sur des positions
inconciliables vous avez ressenti aussi
vous ce dialogue de sourds
oui mais je pense que manuel valls a
raison c'est un promu c'est un projet
local régional c'est pas un projet
national
moi je suis de ceux qui pensent que les
problèmes régionaux il faut qu'il soit
réglé au niveau résume régionale et donc
ou bien vous vous sentez quand même le
combat politique oui bien sûr qu'ils
aient un film bien sûr les
instrumentalisations et cetera mais je
suis toujours frappé de voir que dans ce
pays tout remonte au niveau central au
niveau du premier ministre et c'est
quand on a un problème on demande un
rendez-vous au premier ministre
connaissait les grands faits connais je
le dis sincèrement parce qu'on est un
pays sans doute hyper centralisé mais
ces questions là elles doivent se régler
dans un cadre local ce n'est pas un
projet national
bon voila et et manuel valls a raison de
dire qu'il ya un consensus politique le
projet sur l'ours pour le faire le
projet se fera malgré les oppositions
oui parce que au sens large que le
projet a été décidée parce que le droit
le permet donc là le pôle question très
simple processus se met très simple et
très politique
le sauvetage est ce que vous pensez vous
avez encore besoin des écologistes au
gouvernement bah moi je suis assez
désespérée par l'évolution des
écologistes parce que je pense que
c'était comment dirais-je un partenaire
très important pour nous à la fois sur
le plan idéologique et sur le plan
politique et je suis vraiment consterné
de voir que ce parti qui pouvait être un
appui très important ce soit se retrouve
finalement dans une situation de
fracture de difficultés pour se faire
entendre et c'est une ou un article sur
ce gouvernement une partie gain de
granby est en train de basculer dans une
surenchère qui à mon avis n'est pas
audible une espèce de contestation
permanente de tous bref donc
donc voilà je pense que c'est la saison
du moi pour vous dire ce que je c'est un
grand gâchis
voilà aurait-il leur place aujourd'hui
dans ce gouvernement syrien bien
évidemment certains ont parfaitement
leur place dans le gouvernement il le
soutiennent je pense à françois de rugy
à barbara pompili il ya tout et c'est
simple à celle ci était au petit théo
que eux et eux sont restés je trouve
assez fidèle à l'engagement qui avait
été pris en 2012
et malgré les difficultés essaye de les
affronter et d'avancer je suis beaucoup
plus sévères pour l'attitude de cécile
duflot pour rien vous cacher et pendant
ce temps là on parle d'écologie pour ça
donc les sénateurs ont voté à une très
large majorité un texte très important
qui est celui sur la bio dit
merci tu es texte d'envergure depuis
1976 sur la protection de la nature il
devrait ensuite revenir à l'assemblée
nationale christophe caresche en
deuxième lecture avant une adoption
définitive afin d'en avant la fin de
l'année traite de façon très courte vous
pouvez nous dire peut-être si ce texte
est d'un enjeu majeur et pourquoi est ce
qu'il est aussi noms à coucher près de
quatre ans le texte sur sur la
biodiversité
ça c'est un honnêtement vous êtes
parlementaire c'était très très long
c'est vrai mais ça c'est l'urgence ou
pas sur ce texte peut-être pas il ya eu
les gars calendrier parlementaire bon
voilà ça c'est pas la priorité enfin
tout le monde a l'air quand même de s'en
féliciter donc les textes qui qui qui
sont longs à une discuter et qui arrive
un consensus s'est pas formalisé le
thème aussi sur les collectivités
notamment sur ces nouvelles régions de
france y est le nouveau président des
régions de france qui a été élu c'est
philippe richert tu sais le patron de la
région alsace champagne-ardennes
lorraine
il a été choisi leur place alain rousset
c'est patron de région et stuff carresse
c'est un peu les nouveaux barons si on
ne peut rien faire sans eux notamment
sur la question du chômage c'est le lien
entre le gouvernement le voit ou de lire
très fort qui unit le gouvernement et
ses présidents de région aujourd'hui moi
je
enfin je ne vois pas comme des points de
blocage je vois au contraire comme des
appuis je pense qu'on doit aller vers la
régionalisation plus forte d'un certain
nombre de politiques alain rousset s'est
beaucoup débattu pour cela très
courageusement et d'ailleurs avec raison
moi je l ai soutenu mme à chaque fois
que je le pouvais c'est vrai que dans
les lois de décentralisation il ya
encore beaucoup de choses à faire mais
par exemple sur ce que dit monsieur
bertrand sur l'emploi sur le chômage
je suis tout à fait d'accord pour que
une partie de la politique
d'accompagnement des chômeurs de
l'emploi soit décentralisée au niveau
des régions il faut le faire parce qu'on
sait que c'est là qu'il y à plus
d'efficacité sélection pour répondre à
cela absolument est donc xavier bertrand
a fait des propositions quand je trouve
très positive jeudi au passage qu'un
amendement avait été votée à l'assemblée
nationale pour faire ce que demande
monsieur bertrand et que le gouvernement
s'y était
finn est opposé bon je le regrette c'est
madame iborra qu'ils allaient proposer
cet amendement c'était un amendement
tout à fait pertinents j'espère qu'on va
reprendre ce travail
alors on va passer à la séquence
politique de la semaine mercredi
décision qui n'a pas vraiment surpris
mais qui a frappé tout le monde c'est à
mercredi des accords politiques majeures
c'est la raison invoquée par christiane
taubira pour justifier son départ du
gouvernement après près de quatre ans
passés au ministère de la justice celle
qui incarnait la caution de gauche de la
gauche de françois hollande a repris sa
liberté un départ très commentée germes
andrieu c'est une demi surprise et
surtout une requête incessantes des
républicains qui réclamait sa démission
après ses déclarations contre la
déchéance de nationalité
le statu quo sur la garde des sceaux
était devenue intenable pour
l'opposition la situation dans laquelle
se trouve et madame taubira a été
totalement ahurissante exprimé une
opposition forte réitéré à un texte
porté par le gouvernement et se
maintenir dans le gouvernement était
totalement inédit vous avez au moins 2
ans qui est plus de y'a plus de garde
des sceaux donc de ce point de vue là ça
changera sans doute pas grand chose
simplement ce que ça acte aujourd'hui
c'est clairement une fissure qui qui
s'agrandit au sein de au sein de la
majorité
une démission avec un calendrier très
précis c'est aujourd'hui que s'ouvre le
débat sur la révision constitutionnelle
de la déchéance de nationalité
tout avait déjà été tranchée c'est
manuel valls qui soutiendra le texte
dans l'hémicycle
christiane taubira avait des désaccords
de plus en plus grand avec certaines
politiques du gouvernement je crois que
la problématique de la déchéance de
nationalité a conduit à cette démission
donc à partir de là elle a tiré les
conséquences sûrement de ces désaccords
politiques
avec l'orientation actuelle du
gouvernement sur une affaire comme ça un
moment donné ben ça explose et elle ne
peut pas continuer à être complice d'une
politique qu'elle n'approuve pas une
démission la garde des sceaux acceptée
par françois hollande pour la remplacer
jean jacques urvoas a été nommé ce
député proche de manuel valls présidait
la commission des lois
depuis 2012
est-ce que vous avez été surpris par ce
départ est ce que c'est au contraire la
comprise en politique logique
oui je pense que vers moi en conclusion
tout à fait logique je pense que ça
aurait été très compliqué pour madame
taubira
alors que sont le texte qu'elle aurait
dû porter était en discussion de ne pas
ne pas le présenter ne pas le soutenir
au parlement
je pense qu'il ya un moment
effectivement ou le désaccord devient
devient ingérable donc voilà elle en a
tiré les conclusions et c'est assez
logique l'impression que le chemin ça y
est la route est dégagée ya plus de
contestataires au gouvernement c'est
parti parce qu'il ya deux logiques si
vous voulez il ya une logique
d'efficacité qui passe par la cohérence
qui passe par la cohésion du
gouvernement qu'entendent manuel valls
mais je pense qu'il a raison je
comprends qu'en tant que premier
ministre il soit attaché à cela et puis
il ya une logique de rassemblement et il
ya un moment où ces deux logiques sont
incompatibles surtout quand les
difficultés sont là et qu'elles sont
très importantes
donc effectivement je comprends
qu'aujourd'hui chef du gouvernement du
président de la république privilégient
plutôt une logique d'efficacité et de
cohérence
je le regrette parce que je pense que
sur le rassemblement d'autre aurait
évidemment vocation à être au
gouvernement
mais si c'est pour simplement afficher
ces différences afficher ses désaccords
ça n'a aucun intérêt vous êtes en train
de vous dire que seuls qui ne peuvent
pas être au gouvernement que ceux qui
sont d'accord avec la ligne d'objet il
va je pense qu'aujourd'hui je pense
qu'aujourd'hui cette question elle est
en partie du public va dire que c'est la
logique de cohérence d'efficacité qui
prévaut qui doit prévaloir
et je pense que ce choix il est assez
juste par rapport aux difficultés qui
sont devant nous parce que l'année 2016
va être difficile il va y avoir
probablement là aussi des imprévus et
c'est bon donc cette logique là et
évidemment c'est un pari c'est toujours
un pari de son la politique c'est le
pari que in fine et les français
reconnaîtront cela reconnaîtront la
cohérence reconnaîtront la fidélité dans
l'action ça met du rebond ce qui veut
dire aussi que ces mêmes contestataires
dont vous parliez se sont peut-être
trouvé aussi une nouvelle
chef de file de leur contestation vous
craignez ces citations un je ne sais pas
ce qu'elle veut faire elle
ce que j'attends de l ai pas dit des
choses de manière assez prudente par
rapport à cela moi j'ai beaucoup
d'estimé pour pour elle c'est vraiment
une femme qui a eu qui a porté
d'ailleurs par par sa réflexion par son
verbe pas par par beaucoup de choses par
sa sensibilité
mais je ne sais pas ce qu'elle voudra
faire ce qui est vrai c'est qu'il ya
mais j'allais dire c'est presque devenu
une comment dirais-je un invariant une
un constat il ya une gauche qui s'est
positionné dans laquelle environ 200
dira lé plus dangereux à l'extérieur ou
l'intérieur
je n'en sais rien je ne pose pas la
question comme ça qui en a un certain
qu'ils en aient un certain nombre qui
souhaitent l'instrumentaliser dans leur
combat contre le gouvernement
ça m'a pas échappé et ça n'a pas échappé
aux observateurs
maintenant ça dépendra de ce qu'elle
veut faire elle le bidon de christiane
taubira par le voyage pour tous c'est
quoi moi je pense qu'elle a un bilan
positif
dans un contexte où la justice aussi des
défis tout à fait immenses à relever
voilà c'est plus c'est pas simple pour
la justice parce que c'est une
institution comme beaucoup
d'institutions qui et qui est confronté
à des chocs très importants et notamment
un choc qui est la massification des
contentieux donc c'est une institution
qui qui vit des difficultés je trouve
qu'elle a plutôt bien géré cela elle
agirait quelque chose de manière très
positive
c'est l'indépendance de la justice et
écouter ce que disait manuel valls à
propos du départ de christiane taubira
la gauche au pouvoir est confronté au
réel et parce qu'elle gouverne dans une
période particulièrement difficile
elle doit tenir il ya toujours la
tentation de partir il ya toujours la
tentation de fuir ses responsabilités
quand c'est difficile
elle doit résisté et résisté au cours
des choses pour tracer sa voie et
résister aujourd'hui ça n'est pas
proclamer ce n'est pas faire des
discours
résister c'est se confronter à la
réalité du pays se confronte à la
réalité du bail il a entièrement raison
il ya une gauche qui ne veut pas
gouverner qui ne veut pas assumer la
responsabilité parce qu'elles
considèrent que passer des compromis
c'est trahir voilà et c'est d'ailleurs
aveuglant dans les propos que tiennent
un certain nombre de responsables qui
représentent cette gauche là elles
préfèrent se replier dans le confort qui
consiste à ne jamais comment dirais-je
c'est qu'il sait où cela se règle pas
c'est celle qui dénonce en permanence la
trahison de ceux qui gouvernent
aujourd'hui c'est celle qui se réfugient
dans des postures morales politiques
mais qui ne ne construit rien il ne
construit rien c'est une gauche
destructrice ce n'est pas une gauche qui
construit quoi que ce soit et
honnêtement je leur souhaite bien du
courage parce que quand je vois les uns
et les autres
alors il s'invite entre eux les uns les
autres
bon pour faire quoi personne ne le sait
bon donc c'est une gauche qui est
purement dans la contestation dans la
protestation et qui fondamentalement 9e
à prendre des responsabilités comme si
la déchéance de nationalité d'ailleurs
dans un petit peu plus sur le contenu du
texte avec alix pichot le premier
ministre en personne est venu devant la
commission des lois
présenté le texte du projet de loi
constitutionnelle le coeur du sujet
l'article 2 qui porte sur l'extension de
la déchéance de nationalité pour les
terroristes à l'origine le gouvernement
voulait inscrire cette déchéance pour
les binationaux dans la constitution
face à l'opposition à gauche il a
finalement choisi une formule plus creux
dante
le gouvernement a décidé en accord avec
le président de la république de
proposer une nouvelle rédaction
aucune référence à la binationalité le
figura dans le texte constitutionnel ni
a priori dans la loi ordinaire
le premier ministre a réaffirmé que la
révision constitutionnelle ne pourrait
créer des apatrides
ce qui implique que la déchéance de
nationalité ne s'appliquerait bien qu
binationaux même ceux nés en france
comme l'avait promis le président face
au congrès pour maintenir un principe
d'égalité les autres français pourraient
se voir privés des droits attachés à la
nationalité
le principe d'égalité commandes aussi
bien sur le plan moral que juridique
d'unifier les régime applicable aux
personnes condamnées en courant la
déchéance qu'elle soit naturalisés ou
née française
autre nouveauté le premier ministre
souhaite que la déchéance s'ouvre aussi
aux délits elle ne serait donc plus
limité aux seuls crimes
une concession faite à la droite qui
souhaite un élargissement du champ
d'application de la déchéance à ces
annonces l'opposition prise de court et
mais un premier avis plutôt prudent mais
semble rester ouverte au dialogue il
faut encore qu'on est la démonstration
que ce soit bien par une révision de la
constitution qu'on arrive au plus
d'efficacité
voilà où l'eau reste à ce stade tant
qu'on n'a pas d'autres éléments les
débats dans l'hémicycle débuteront le 5
février prochain
alors la référence à la binationalité ne
figurera donc plus noir sur blanc dans
le texte et pourtant certains à gauche
dit c'est un jeu d'écriture c'est une
hypocrisie ce matin pascal cherki parlé
de forfaiture politique vous la répondez
quoi bon se creuse outrancier
nous voulons de parler de sa part en
particulier non je pense que c'est une
très bonne chose je trouve que la
l'écriture qui a été introduite la seule
chose que je regrette c'est qu'elle a
été introduite dès le début voilà
soyons clair ça aurait peut-être évité
les allez tout d'un certain nombre de
wii un certain nombre d'interrogations
parce que ce qui est évidemment les
binationaux ne sont pas concernés en
tant que binationaux il serait concerné
s'il commettait des actes de terrorisme
brise vent c'est terrorisant on sait
donc que soyons clairs ils commettent
des délits graves
c'est ou des délits graves ou et bien
sûr crimes et d'alliances un jour cette
affaire elle et elle et elle est très
symbolique au fond donc ce que fait le
gouvernement c'est qu'il retire le
symbole et c'est vrai que beaucoup ont
dit j'ai encore vu patrick weil
on en a discuté encore cette semaine la
fondation jean jaurès
beaucoup ont dit le problème c'est que
ce soit dans la constitution
c'est pas le fait qu'il y ait des
chances de nationalité d'ailleurs les
chances de traiter elle existe dans
notre droit d'où l'hésitation c'est que
ce soit dans notre constitution dans
d'autres pays donc je trouve que il a le
gouvernement à retirer au fond quelque
chose qui je pense doit apaiser le débat
et y parvenir on savait que ce soit dans
la constitution non pardon si c'était
symbolique nomination excusez moi je
parle des binationaux oui il fallait que
la déchéance de nationalité soit dans la
constitution d'ailleurs c'est ce que dit
l'avis du conseil d'état
moi je pense que sur ce point là le
gouvernement a eu raison de suivre
l'avis du conseil d'état
parce que ça et vise évidemment vous
voyez que le gouvernement fait des
compromis qu'ils arrivent à satisfaire
manoeuvre bien sûr mais mais mais de
même que le le pré le premier ministre à
rechercher ce qui est bien normal
l'adhésion à la fois de la gauche ou
d'une partie de la gauche pour ce cas
une partie de la gauche ce sont qui ne
votera pas voter le texte toujours une
pour les mêmes raisons ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure
donc les goûts dans une protestation de
principe si vous voulez bon donc ils ne
voteront pas mais je pense que beaucoup
et notamment j'ai vu qu'au sein du
groupe socialiste
un certain nombre de ceux qui avaient
des interrogations
se sont ralliés à cette donc vous pensez
qu'il y aura une majorité pour voter
c'est le deuxième point c'est que le
premier ministre a aussi essayé de faire
des compromis de l'autre côté parce que
il faut trois cinquièmes pour weepu
parfaitement le jeu
vous rappelle que la dernière révision
constitutionnelle de 2008 a été votée à
une voix donc n'oubliez jamais qu'une
révision concessionnels rien et c'est
toujours excuser moi un exercice à haut
risque donc c'est compliqué et président
et politique
oui c'est dangereux mais parce que il en
a fait il en a fait le la condition du
rassemblement de l'unité nationale et
donc c'est la raison dans ce sens ce
moment là de faire dans un moment de
aussi comment dirais-je de d'un choc
aussi fort de vouloir essayer de
rassembler les français donc de
rassembler les forces politiques ou si
je changeais bien plus union abbas est
clair que ceux qui voteront contre la
révision conscio neil voteront contre
l'unité nationale pour moi c'est très
clair
alors on va s'intéresser à au successeur
de christiane taubira volée bien que
vous connaissez bien
jean jacques urvoas ses taux jeudi
jean-jacques urvoas et donc le nouveau
ministre de la justice il était jusqu
alors président de la commission des
lois voyons les dossiers qui seront sur
sa table avec stéphane et des pierres
premier chantier de jean jacques urvoas
la réforme constitutionnelle un objectif
dans la droite ligne de son travail à la
tête de la commission des lois à
l'assemblée nationale depuis quelques
semaines il était chargé par manuel
valls de trouver la formulation magique
pour inclure la déchéance de nationalité
dans la constitution
pour le reste le nouveau ministre de la
justice n'affiche pas des ambitions
démesurées
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire pendant
15 mois mon engagement se nouera sera de
ne pas chercher à bouleverser l'univers
judiciaire
mais à me concentrer sur la prise en
charge du présent seul gage d'un futur
maîtrisé pourtant christiane taubira
quitte la chancellerie ion les sont deux
gros dossiers sur la table la réforme de
la justice des mineurs
attendu depuis deux ans est sans cesse
repoussée ce texte voulant favoriser
l'éducatif et la prévention n'est
toujours pas à l'agenda parlementaire et
le nouveau garde des sceaux ne l'a pas
évoquée lors de la passation de pouvoir
autre projet cher à l'ancien ministre la
justice du 21e siècle annonce
2014 et qui semble aussi au point mort
au grand projet jean jacques urvoas
préfèrent les actions concrètes notre
justice aujourd'hui en permanence au
bord de l'embolie et donc je vais
m'attacher pendant les quinze mois qui
viennent va faire en sorte que la seule
loi d'importance soit votée c'est à dire
la loi de finances enfin le nouveau
ministre de la justice devra faire
passer au parlement la réforme pénale
dont le volet sécuritaire inquiète une
partie du monde judiciaire
car elle vous présente jean jarrassé
notre partenaire biscan qui va vous
intéresser alors quelques petites
minutes d'abord katia sur jean jacques
urvoas
jean jacques urvoas à peine nommé qui a
imposé un peu sa marque est-ce que c'est
l'homme qu'il fallait à ce poste l'on
voit c'est the right man at the right
place comme on dit en bon français
oui mais voilà quand le garantit pas
c'est donc vous faites non non c'est un
très bon choix et et je pense qu'il a à
la fois l'expérience la compétence il
est extrêmement reconnu à au parlement
et je crois ce qu'il a dit est très
juste la justice encore une fois est
confrontée à une massification des
contentieux un choc extrêmement
importants comme l'éducation nationale
lors d'un certain point de vue avec la
démocratisation de l'enseignement et
donc c'est vrai qu'il faut des moyens il
faut des moyens et il faut encore plus
de moyens
et vous pensez de la région de dire que
la loi de finances qui sait qu'elle aura
gain de cause
mais déjà on a fait beaucoup d'efforts
et d'ailleurs je constate que c'est des
efforts qui ont été plutôt continue dans
compris avec les albums dans les
dernières années y compris les alternat
ministères prioritaires
oui absolument il ya eu beaucoup d'aidé
continuer à faire un effort jean jacques
urvoas et quand même connu pour être
assez proche de la police en tout cas de
tout ce qui est du côté de l'intérieur
est ce que vous n'avez pas la crainte
que la police prédomine la justice
aujourd'hui
non d'abord
jean jacques est un professeur de droit
public
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas il ay là il a
travaillé sur les questions de sécurité
à la demande d'ailleurs de martine aubry
quand il était secrétaire national à ces
questions mais il vient d'abord du droit
c'était un homme de droit de c'est un
juriste dans un livre dans un livre 2011
s'il voulait rassembler police alors que
steve se dire je connais très bien et
vous les supprimez la préfecture de
police ils voulaient bon oui ce livre
c'est c'était tout les propos toutes les
réformes qui ne seront pas fait a donc
voila c'était c'est à dire rien c'est
d'ailleurs à côté le préfet délivre
alors c'est un côté tout à fait oui mais
ça sert à réfléchir
c'est un côté sympathique et éminemment
intéressant chez jean jacques urvoas
c'est que c'est un homme qui a beaucoup
de liberté l'intellectuel est
effectivement il avait écrit un livre
assez amusant surtout s'il ne devrait
pas faire en politique c'est toutes les
réformes qui ne fallait pas faire et
qu'ils ne se feront pas aimé qui
permettait effectivement de poser un
certain nombre de débats qui sont des
vrais débats
ça va lui faire plaisir voit passer tout
de suite à notre rubrique avec jim
jarrassé jim c'est à vous on commence
par une phrase qui était prononcée cette
semaine par aurélie filippetti on le
sait qui et opposante à la question de
la déchéance de nationalité
le gouvernement de françois hollande at
elle dit prend un virage autoritaire
comment en est on arrivé à cette
situation une députée socialiste qui
plus est ancien ministre accuse
l'exécutif d'une quasi dérive
dictatoriale
oui c'est une plaisanterie qui peut
prendre qui peut croire ça qui peut
prendre ça au sérieux
ça vous a laissé des déclarations qui
sont tellement excessive qu'elle
devienne effectivement insignifiante
personne ne peut croire que la france
est en train de
d'entrée dans une danse dans un régime
policier ou autoritaire ce n'est pas
sérieux télé but de cette surcharge
puisque vous la décrivez ainsi je pense
qu'il ya peut-être du ressentiment
personnel chez certains qui ont été
ministres qui sont plus c'est toujours
difficile évidemment
enfin un bon os qu'elle incarne aurélie
filippetti et les autres la gauche
destructrice dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure
parle à travers ses déclarations oui
parce que je pense que faire croire aux
français que nous allons vers un régime
dictatorial si vous voulez c'est pas
c'est pas sérieux et il faut moi ce qui
me frappe c'est que dans dans la dans le
débat public aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup
de responsables politiques qui
s'expriment de manière irresponsable
il faut il faut il faut garder quand
même la rigueur au moins intellectuel
ils ont été plusieurs à prendre position
justement profitant du départ de
christiane taubira on a entendu benoît
hamon d'antenne delphine batho on est
entendu
arnaud montebourg qui a qui a fait un
tweet pour féliciter mme christiane
taubira de son départ est-ce que
l'exécutif doit craindre la constitution
une sorte de ligue d'anciens ministres
entrer en résistance condamné je cours
je comprends qu'il y ait des
déclarations sur christiane taubira de
sympathie de proximité et ça moi je n'ai
pas du tout de problème avec ça et dont
ceux que vous avez cités il ya sans
doute cette cette dimension par contre
c'est vrai que certains et depuis
maintenant des mois sont entrés dans une
logique dans une stratégie qui est une
stratégie alternative à ce que l'on fait
ce que fait le parti socialiste c'est
donc la question est de savoir jusqu'où
ils vont aller où cela va-t-il les mener
moi je n'en sais rien ça leur appartient
ça leur appartient cette question leur
appartient ils faut qu'ils y répondent
mais le risque c'est je crois aux
mutations de l'éthique c'est destructeur
parce que je ne crois pas à ces
alternatives je n'en crois le ton je n'y
crois d'autant moins que les français
n'ont pas l'air d'être un très attiré
par les les quand ils votent par les
thèses qui sont défendues par ces
responsables politiques la même
orientation autres de gauche pour 2010
oui peut-être je ne l'exclus pas mais il
ya un moment où il faut aussi que les
choses soient posées et une fille née
c'est quand même les français des
électeurs qui tranchent ces questions là
ceci dit en 2017 faudra quand même être
un peu prudent parce qu' une telle
confrontation affaiblir et
inévitablement probablement le celui qui
pourrait représenter la gauche au
deuxième tour
donc il y aura là des responsabilités
très lourdes à prendre il ya un autre
type de deux frondeurs qui joue un peu
sa petite musique personnelle il s'agit
d'anne hidalgo vous qui êtes élu
parisien vous la connaissez bien
elle s'est à nouveau opposée à le
week-end dernier à la volonté d'
emmanuel macron de remettre en cause les
35 heures c'est la nouvelle martine
aubry non je veux pas d'eux j'ai pas de
2,2 critique à franck lui fait vis-à-vis
de ces pas freiné les algues ou deux
noms mais je je je vois là je la
respecte elle est maire de paris elle
fait un bon travail à paris pour le
reste je pense qu'il faut encore une
fois que dans la période où nous sommes
et en particulier à gauche nous avons
une responsabilité particulière nous
sommes au pouvoir nous sommes en
responsabilité
il faut veiller à ce que les propos
soient respectueux des uns et des autres
face à la fronde l'ale droite du ps dont
vous faites partie se structurer veut
faire entendre sa voix on l'a bien
compris le pool des réformateurs dont
vous faites parti qui s'est constitué
autour de soutien de manuel valls s'est
dotée début janvier d'une association de
financement
donc ça sert à collecter des dons oui à
quoi ça sert une fille ça sert à
financer les maigres activités que nous
avons devant organisé par exemple une
journée d'été avec emmanuel macron
d'ailleurs à sac léognan chez mon ami
gilles savary et ça suppose quelques
petits moyens des petits moyens je
j'insiste là dessus et vous savez
peut-être nous ne savons pas que les
micro partis permettent de collecter ça
sera toujours
s'agit en aucun cas préparer une
éventuelle candidature prédit de
personnes et de manuel valls en
particulier sera bien l'actualité du
jour c'est françois hollande qui reçoit
aujourd'hui la famille de jacqueline
sauvage cette mère de famille qui en
prison après avoir tué son mari qui la
battait et abusé également de ses
enfants
de nombreux responsables politiques à
gauche comme à droite on pris position
en faveur de jacqueline sauvage et
réclament notamment une grâce
présidentielle est ce que vous êtes
favorable je suis très réservé sur cette
question parce que il y a eu deux
jugement en cour d'assises
je vous rappelle que la gauche parce que
c'est nous qui l'avons mis dans la loi
mais après que la droite les engager a
décidé de créer un appel en cour
d'assises et à partir de là je considère
que c'est très compliqué de 2
remettre en cause un jugement devait le
petit c'est pas le rôle des politiques
la grâce présidentielle au passage c'est
quand même un héritage de la monarchie
s'est passé par c'est pas quelque chose
de très très républicain mais surtout
dès lors qu'il y à cet appel qu'il y a
eu deux de jugement c'est quand même
compliqué je vais vous dire ce que je
pense fondamentalement c'est que je
pense que cette personne a été très mal
défendu
parce que ses avocates ont voulu ce qui
est une erreur
les avocats le savent ont voulu défendre
une cause ou plutôt qu'une personne donc
si on vous entend bien pas vraiment pour
la grâce présidentielle
vous souhaiteriez que merci d'avoir ça
appartient au président de la république
en propre mais moi je suis réservé je
pense que pour parler clairement dans
ces situations là la grâce
présidentielle devrait même être
supprimés et ben voilà ce sera le mot de
la fin de cette émission merci beaucoup
christophe cage avoir été l'invité de
parlement hebdo très bonne semaine à
tous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour parlement hebdo